[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: As usual,
let's find out where we are.
We did the first two sections
of general equilibrium
on welfare and existence.
And now, we're going to do
Gorman aggregation today,
and then finish this
segment with identification.
We have two lectures to
finish out the class.
So that's where we are.
In terms of the
reading list for today,
there's only one
thing there, and it's
the place from where I
drew a lot of the material
for the welfare theorem
for the Gorman aggregation
and my colleague Daron.
It is starred, but
it is also pretty
extensively covered
today as well.
Then we have the study guide.
So last time, we did
concepts of existence
in various distinct ways.
There aren't too many
review questions here.
I didn't ask the
first set of them.
But we get down to Negishi.
So how does Negishi use the
first and second welfare
theorems to generate a mapping
in lambda weights, the fixed
point of which is a
competitive equilibrium?
And since I was calling
on everyone last time,
let me just take volunteers.
Hopefully, there are volunteers.
AUDIENCE: I was--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Go on.
AUDIENCE: You go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I was
about to say that I
was a little unclear
on the proof overall,
but I remember that we use
the fact that for any lambda,
the corresponding period
of optimal allocation
would be in equilibrium
with transfers
by the second welfare theorem,
and we use that to prove
Negishi's theorem.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, that's right.
We used to have the
second one heavily.
The first one is that any
competitive equilibrium
is Pareto optimal, and hence,
it corresponds to some lambda
weights in the Pareto problem.
So Negishi's mapping
is to find a way
to find the particular
special lambdas
of the competitive equilibrium
with private ownership that is
the fixed point of his mapping.
I realized after
class, in part talking
with one of you who came to
office hours, that I never--
I think I neglected
to say the obvious.
What I did say is to
find the lambda such
that the valuation
of expenditures
under the Pareto of optimum
uses using the second welfare
theorem is equal to the
valuation of the endowment
plus shares on profits
that corresponds
to the competitive equilibrium.
But what I think I
neglected to say was--
maybe I did say it.
Bears repeating.
That if you initially
guess a lambda which
is high than the value for
a particular household, then
the valuation of that
household's expenditures
will be large relative to
the valuation of wealth
in the private
ownership economy.
So sort of intuitively, then,
you lower that lambda weight.
That links up to something
we learned when we did this
the second welfare
theorem, which
is, those lambdas are
inversely proportional to
the marginal utility of wealth.
So if the lambda is too
high, the guy has too much--
the evaluation of
expenditures is too high.
So the marginal utility of
wealth with concave utility
is low.
So you want to move in the
direction of increasing
the marginal utility of wealth,
which effectively removes
wealth by lowering lambda.
So anyway, thank you.
Next question.
Define a mixed-strategy
Nash equilibrium.
AUDIENCE: I think
I can do this one.
Like, a mixed-strategy
Nash equilibrium is--
it's a type of Nash
equilibrium where at least some
of the players are--
choose some of the
options that are random?
So there's some
weighted probabilities
where you can have some chance
of doing option A, some chance
of doing option B, and so on.
And in order for it to work, the
player who is doing mixed stuff
has to be indifferent
from all of the things
with non-zero between all
of the different options
with non-zero probabilities, and
it also has to be in such a way
that, again, no one
has any incentive
to deviate from the strategy.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Right.
The last thing,
especially, is key.
So the mixed-strategy Nash
equilibrium is taking--
each player takes as given
a configuration of mixed
strategies of the others--
sort of star strategy,
so to speak-- and then
feels free to choose the
best one for his or herself.
But that will end up
being exactly the star
strategy to begin with.
So it's, like, self-fulfilling
in the space of strategies.
Thank you.
That was a good answer.
And then the last one.
How do we give an
incentive for traders
to live up to their
promises and achieve
over raising an equilibrium?
So I did this in the context
of the market for trades
in US treasuries in New York.
Which is a trade agreed to
by treasury for liquidity.
I mentioned that, in
fact, there were trade
fails where they don't
live up to their agreement
because the party selling
the treasury doesn't own it,
can't transfer it at the
time, when a settlement is due
or the person who
promised to pay liquidity
doesn't have
sufficient liquidity.
And then I mapped that into
the Walrasian equilibrium
framework.
So let me ask it again.
How do we give an
incentive for trades--
trade-- for traders,
I guess it should be,
to live up to their promise
and achieve a Walrasian
equilibrium?
Anybody remember?
AUDIENCE: I remember there was
a penalty for liquidity, right?
If the creditor was negative,
then it will have this utility.
And so you're in--
so in the end, in order to
achieve the [? variation ?]
allocation, we need to
let all of the downwards--
or there was a--
we need to let the
[? operator ?] equal to 0
so that there was no
exercise demand, no--
yeah.
I mean--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
Yeah, that's good.
AUDIENCE: We should
we want to promise
that if the endowment is equal
to the allocations, the extent
of the allocation.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Right.
That's good.
So the problem is,
they're submitting bids,
and we're looking for
a Nash equilibrium.
The bids consist of orders to
buy and also orders to sell.
We're shooting for the
Walrasian equilibrium,
in particular, the
budget constraints.
So we want, for each
trader, that the valuation
of what they're
buying is at least
matched by the valuation
of what they're selling.
In other words, they have
sufficient liquidity.
And if we didn't put in a
penalty, everybody would
overspend, because why not?
So yeah, so then the
penalty that you mentioned--
so beta is negative.
When beta is
negative, that means
they're spending more
than they have in revenue.
That's a bad thing.
So we effectively make
the penalty beta--
sorry, I can't
remember the notation.
I think it was
lambda times beta--
sufficiently high so then
they do the right trade-off.
They look at how much they
would get in utility from buying
this stuff directly and weigh
that against the disutility
of the penalty.
The magnitude of the penalty had
to do with the marginal utility
of income, that
Lagrange multiplier
we keep focusing on in the
competitive equilibrium
and the budget constraint.
So the margin utility of income
represents the incremental gain
from having epsilon
more liquidity.
And they're tempted
to spend more
than they have to go in
that epsilon direction,
but the penalty is large enough
so as to dominate that gain,
and they don't deviate.
Well, in earmarking
this question,
I recognized that we
rushed a bit at the end.
In fact, I went over the class
time by a couple of minutes.
So anyway, hopefully,
that was a useful review.
Any other questions
from last time?
OK.
So now, I want to
get to aggregation.
This is kind of an exciting
lecture in the sense
that it goes back and
reviews some of the things
we've been doing before--
certainly, the basics
of consumer theory
with utility maximization,
some things about Lagrangians
and envelope theorems.
It also goes back to
the first application
we have had of consumers
maximizing utility
subject to budgets,
and what happens
when income changes, and so on.
So we already talked about
angles, curves, and Giffen
goods, and so on.
And so you have the
micro background already.
So you can judge
the plausibility
of the assumptions we're
about to make in order
to allow the aggregation.
And the aggregation was used
when we did, like, free trade.
We would talk about a
representative consumer, not
just Robinson Crusoe,
one man on the island,
but someone representing
the entire US population.
So that is a big leap of faith.
Today, we'll spell out
what it takes to do that.
So this is going to
be Gorman aggregation,
and we're going to do it in the
positive sense of predicting
what will happen and in the
normative sense of making
statements about
consumer welfare.
And then we're going to
have indirect utility
functions, Gorman Polar
forms, and the rest I already
mentioned.
So some micro, but
mostly macro economists,
assume the
representative consumer
or representative agents.
It kind of comes
naturally, because they're
worrying about aggregates,
not distributional aspects.
So that gives them and us a
tractable way of understanding
market demand--
and supply, for that matter--
and allows pretty
easy welfare analysis
because there's only one person.
So those are all the
advantages, but we'll
see how realistic it is.
So here's the utility
maximization problem.
Maximizing-- we'll suppress the
labels here for households i
and h and so on.
So this household has a utility
function represented by u of x,
where x is in the consumption
set and the valuation
of expenditures at prices
p cannot exceed wealth w.
So we call the solution to this
problem, after maxing it out--
the achieved maximized
utility is called the value.
And this function v is called
the indirect utility function,
v for value.
So it takes as
given the parameters
that the household
takes as given,
namely, the price
vector p and wealth w.
So it is the maximal
attainable utility
in the budget set as a
function of those parameters.
And the bottom line here-- you
can just see, if x of p and w
is the maximizer, we
just stick it back
into the utility
function, and that
would be the optimized value.
So there are very
useful properties
of this indirect
utility function,
and they are reviewed
on this slide.
Let's assume the
consumption set is
a subset of finite dimensional,
L-dimensional Euclidean space.
Utility functions
are continuous,
representing a
preference relation that
is rational and continuous.
The indirect utility
just defined.
First of all, this v as
a function of p and w
is homogeneous of
degree 0 in p and w,
because as you already know, if
you, for example, double prices
and wealth, it doesn't change
the picture of consumer
maximization and you
get the same solution.
It's like, there's no
money illusion here.
If price is double, but
wealth loss also doubles,
you're just as well off as you
were before, and not worse off.
This indirect utility function
has intuitive derivatives
with respect to p and w.
Increasing p makes you worse
off, or at least not better
off.
Increasing w makes
you better off.
w is wealth.
Prices are what you have to pay.
In fact, that indirect utility
will be strictly increasing
in w when we have local
non-satiation, which
is what we're always
going to be assuming here.
The indirect utility function
is quasi-convex, not concave--
convex in p and w.
So again, when we did consumer
theory, we had concave utility.
Upper contour sets
where quasi-convex,
but the utility
function was concave.
This maximized utility
over the budget
is convex, or at
least quasi-convex.
Continuous, which is easy to
assume, and differentiable.
And when the indirect utility
function is differentiable,
we can use it to recover demand.
And the proof is
pretty easy, but here,
it looks kind of
amazing, I suppose,
which is if we want the
maximized quantity of good L
for this consumer facing
price vector p and wealth w,
the answer will be
take the derivative
of the indirect utility function
with respect to the L-th price,
and divide by the derivative
of the indirect utility
function with respect to wealth,
and stick a negative sign
in front of all of that.
So here's a little proof of it.
We have the Lagrangian,
which represents a utility
maximization problem,
with 0 being the shadow
price of the budget and the L--
sorry, are lambda sub
0, and lambda sub L
being potential shadow prices
on non-negativity constraints.
So we're going to use the
envelope theorem, which
to remind you,
states that you can
take a derivative with
respect to the parameters
of the optimization problem,
in this case, p and w.
And if you take the derivatives
at the optimizing solution
to get sort of the increment
in utility associated
with changing those parameters.
So the increment in utility
from solving the max problem
at those parameters is also the
derivative of the Lagrangian
with respect to
those parameters.
So there's, like,
two steps there--
how to represent the
maximum value, namely,
as a solution to the Lagrangian,
and also the envelope theorem
that tells you--
reminds you that the derivative
of the optimized solution
with respect to the parameter
is, like, differentiating
at the maximizing quantities.
So too many words.
So the first derivative here
in equation 3, the derivative
of the value function with
respect to a particular price
pl is the derivative of
the Lagrangian with respect
to-- at price pl evaluated
at the maximum, namely,
x sub p and w is the demand.
And going back upstairs
here, derivative
of the Lagrangian with respect
to pl, where does it appear?
It only appears
here in the budget.
So you get a lambda 0,
and p is linear in x.
So you get the x sub l back,
and that's this object.
Likewise, the derivative
with the indirect utility
with respect to w, derivative
of the Lagrangian with respect
to w wealth, evaluated at
the maximizing solution.
There's only one
place that w appears.
It's up here.
So you just get lambda 0.
So lambda 0 is
now in 4 and in 3.
Substitute the
expression in 4 into 3,
and you get dv dp l equal to--
well, it's all written out here.
Just basically
taking the lambda 0,
looking at the left-hand
side, sticking it in here,
and then repeating the x sub l.
So now, solve this
equation for x sub l
and you get what
we wanted, namely,
the ratio of the derivative
with respect to p
divided by-- with respect
to w with the minus
sign in front of it.
So we get what we wanted.
Questions?
So that's an interesting problem
of the indirect utilities.
Now, we're ready to define
a particular version
of the indirect utility function
called Gorman Polar form,
or Gorman form.
This doesn't always
happen, but it can happen.
For particular
utility functions,
the indirect utility
function in p and w
has an intercept
and a slope and.
The intercept is a
function of vector p.
The slope b with respect to
w is a function of vector p,
and it's linear in w.
And I'll show you an
example right now,
because this seems
a bit mysterious.
So let's go back to our
favorite utility function,
this sort of Cobb
Douglass, with two goods,
x1 and x2, raised to the
power alpha and 1 minus alpha.
You may remember that
these alphas and 1 minus
alpha represent the
expenditure share
in the optimized solution.
So p1 times x1 is alpha times w.
So this household spends alpha
fraction of its wealth, w,
on good 1, and spends 1 minus
alpha times w on good 2.
I'm just shifting these prices
over here to the left-hand side
so it's not just quantity.
It's quantity times
price or value.
So with each Cobb Douglas, it's
constant expenditure shares.
More on that momentarily.
And now, the definition
of indirect utility
says, just substitute
in the maximized value.
So we take Ux1, but use
this expression for x1
to the alpha x to
this expression for x2
to the 1 minus alpha.
That's this business.
And when you solve it
out, you get of a of p,
looking for it to
be in this form.
a of p is 0, and b of p is
this coefficient, [INAUDIBLE]
alpha 1 minus alpha p1 and
p2 to these powers alpha
and 1 minus alpha.
That's b of p.
It depends on p and
on nothing else.
And it is indeed linear in w.
The linearity in w just
comes from the property that
alpha plus 1 minus alpha is 1.
w the alpha times w
to the 1 minus alpha.
Just add up the
power coefficients.
So this is all, so far,
for a single household,
hence neglecting to
put in notation h or i,
or whatever label
the household is.
However, if this
Cobb Douglas function
were the same over
all of the households,
then we have a
Gorman Polar form,
where all of the households
have the same intercept, a of p,
and the same slope term, b of p.
Likewise, if it were to be the
case that the alpha coefficient
varies across over
the households,
then this BSP is not going
to be common over all
of the households.
It's going to depend on
particular preferences.
So maybe that's illustrative
just how tenuous, already,
the assumption is going to be.
But it is going to be very
powerful if it's true.
So let's go at it and talk
about aggregate demand.
So we have an economy with
I households, I agents.
Their wealths are w1 through wI.
A wealth profile.
Let's define w bar to be the
aggregate total wealth, just
by summing up all of
the individual wealths.
And retain this notation
that xI of p and wI
is the demand
function for agent I.
The aggregate demand,
x bar, by definition,
will be the sum of the
individual demands.
And we write that notationally
as x bar of the vector--
the parameters of the problem,
namely, the common price vector
and individual wealths.
So that's the definition
of aggregate demand.
Nothing so far other
than the definition.
But the first question
about aggregation
is, can we find an aggregate
demand function that is special
in that it only depends on
total wealth in the population,
not how the wealth is
distributed in the population?
So the idea here is
this x bar of L--
which, again, was just defined.
But now, for the L-th
good, x bar of L at p and w
is the aggregate demand.
We're looking for this
function, capital X, now, of L--
capital, I guess,
for big aggregate,
which is a function of p,
of course, but now w bar.
So here's the content of it.
Or looking at it
this way, vector p,
yes, but the wealth component
in the aggregate demand
depends on the sum of
individual wealths only.
It doesn't depend
on the distribution.
On this slide, wealth enter
each agent's demand function.
And there's no
reason why it should
be representable to depend
only on the aggregate.
But we're going to look for
specifications of utility
where that's true.
And we haven't even asked
whether that aggregate demand
function, that capital X, comes
from some underlying utility
function as a solution.
We're just looking for
whether it depends only
on aggregate wealth,
or rather, might
depend on the distribution.
But this is a necessary
condition for there
to be a representative
household that's
maximizing some pseudo-utility
function that's going
to represent aggregate demand.
So we're kind of doing
one thing at a time.
So what is a necessary
condition for us
to be able to
aggregate up like that?
And it is that the
marginal impact
of wealth changes on demands,
say, for the L-th good,
is the same over all
of the households,
and that is also true
for all of the goods.
So whatever good L you pick,
whatever pairwise households I
and J you pick, they need
each to have the same income
effect of how demand
changes with wealth.
And here's the picture, which
you've kind of seen before.
These are linear
wealth expansion paths.
We're holding prices fixed of
the two goods, in this case.
And for consumer-- one
of these consumers,
we're tracing out the optimized
solution as we change wealth--
optimizing in the sense that
the household has achieved
maximal utility for
any given wealth
characterized by a tangency
between the indifference
curve and the budget line.
The other households
up here also
has a linear expansion path.
Now, it's true that
this household--
I, it is-- has higher
levels of demand for good 2
relative to good 1 than is
the case for household J.
So they're not identical.
But when you think about what
happens when you redistribute
wealth with these parallel
linear expansion paths,
the derivatives are the same.
We could, for example, take some
wealth away from household I.
We would move southwest.
We'd have the change in
x1, x2, and the change
in x1 little
triangle over there,
and give that
wealth to household
J, who would be
moving northeast.
But again, because these
lines are parallel,
we're going to have exactly
the same changes [INAUDIBLE]..
So the levels can be
different, but the derivatives
are the same.
And that picture represents
this condition 10,
that the income
effects are the same
over all of the households.
And that's a necessary condition
for only aggregate wealth
to matter.
Individual demands are moving
as you redistribute the wealth.
But what one guy gives up
is what the other guy gains.
So the total demand
isn't moving.
Who gets what is moving,
but not the total demand,
as we redistribute the wealth.
The next step is to find a
utility function that's going
to give that aggregate demand.
We're going to call this guy
the positive representative
household.
So let's have the
consumption set
be a subset of this
L-dimension Euclidean space.
The individual demands,
xI of vector p and wI
for households I
over all of them
to be the individual demands.
We're looking for a preference
ordering with a star on it
on the aggregate
consumption set,
and a particular utility
function, u star,
that represents this
preference ordering.
And that object, consumption
set and the preference ordering
in particular, is said to
represent or correspond
with a positive
representative household
if and only if the aggregate
demand, that capital
X of p and w bar, comes from
the utility maximization problem
where the utility function
is of the form u star.
So again, we're used to
utility maximization.
u star is some utility function.
We maximize it.
Oh, subject to the budget,
what is the budget?
It's like giving
this, quote, "person,"
this representative
household, the entire wealth
of the economy, w bar.
And this X thing, in
case you've forgotten,
this capital X of p and w bar,
was the object way back here
that we were looking
for, the aggregate demand
as a function only of
the sum of the wealths,
or aggregate wealth.
So under what conditions can
we find this amazing u star?
Yep, Gorman Polar form.
So a necessary and
sufficient condition
to get that equation
tend to be true
is that everybody's preferences
can be represented by 16,
namely, now with the
I's to be explicit,
the indirect utility function
for household or agent
I has this intercept and slope.
The intercept term can
actually depend on i.
We do allow that degree
of heterogeneity.
But the slope with
respect to w and wI
for household I does
not depend on i.
Common slope terms.
So again, to write
it out, the way
the indirect utility functions
for i and j respond to wealth
is the same.
Namely, it's bp, which
is not quite the picture
we were looking at,
but it's getting close,
as you can imagine.
So if 16 is true over
all households i,
then we can find
our amazing u star,
or in particular,
the indirect utility
function corresponding
to u star.
And it's going to look a lot
like the individual indirect
utility functions in
the sense that it's
written down as a times b of w.
The a star for the
representative consumer
is the sum of the
aI of ps over i.
So we just add them up.
And the b star is
the common b of p
over all of the households i.
So then this guy, represented by
the indirect utility function,
is the positive
representative household.
So it's an if and only thing,
but let's just go one way.
If and only if means if
they have these polar forms,
then it's
Gorman-agreeable and we
have a representative consumer.
And also, if we have a
representative consumer,
then the underlying
households have
to have utility
represented by 16.
So let's just go one way.
Suppose that preferences have
indirect utility functions that
satisfy 16.
We'll go from the micro
to the macro, so to speak.
Now, we use Roy's identity.
You were probably wondering
why we ever had that.
So demand of household i
for good l at price vector
p and wealth wi is just
this ratio of derivatives
with the minus sign out front.
And now, we use the
particular forms, namely,
the derivative of the
indirect utility function
with respect to wi is
namely just b of p,
because that's that
coefficient there.
And the derivative of the
indirect utility function
with respect to p is what?
Well, go back here.
It's indirect utility
function for household i.
Take derivatives with respect
to the intercept and the slope
term with respect to p.
So that's what's
written out here,
the derivative of the
intercept and slope
terms with respect to p.
And of course, that w is hanging
on there as a coefficient.
So this must be true.
Now, having derived the
demands of household i,
we can take the derivative
with respect to wealth.
And it's just going
to appear here.
So we get this times this as
the way demand is changing.
Well, one thing you can
see, on the right-hand side
here, there's no i.
So the change in demands
with respect to wealth
are the same across
all of the households,
and equal to this common
term on the right-hand side.
So this gives us that with
the indirect utility function,
we have these constant
income effects
over all of the households.
Now, the second thing we want
to show is not just that,
but that we can find this
amazing representative
consumer.
So we want-- when we maximize
whatever this v star is with
respect to--
when we get this maximized
solution for this star
representative consumer
and aggregate wealth w,
it should represent the sum
of the individual demands.
So you have this
expression already for--
let me remind you, the v
star, the candidate, is 17.
So we're going to
prove that it works.
Take v star indirect utility
to be this a star, b star,
w bar term.
Then by Roy's identity, that's
just another indirect utility
function.
So the demand that comes from
it at the aggregate wealth w bar
and price vector p
would just be the ratio
of these marginal effects
with a negative sign
out in front of it.
And of course, we know
the form of v star.
So at an aggregated level,
it's very much like before,
1 over bp, because that's
just the wealth coefficient.
And p enters into the
intercept and slope
term in this
aggregated equation--
aggregate indirect utility 17.
So we get this.
Remember that the
a star is the sum
of the ai's by construction.
So now, that is all written
out very explicitly.
Nothing going on with wealth.
But now, we get to just
take this summation
and pull it outside.
So we have the
demand that we want
is the summation over i of
what's left over after pulling
out the summation.
We have the individual terms.
But of course, that is
nothing other than, again,
from Roy's identity, the
underlying demands, which,
when we sum them up,
is aggregate demand.
So we've used this particular
utility function, 17,
to derive the aggregate
demand, which is now
proved to be the sum of
the individual demands,
and by this construction,
depends only
on aggregate wealth.
The w bar is missing there.
Questions?
All right.
So let me give you an example
of the underlying utility
functions and consumption sets.
Suppose, being explicit
about the heterogeneity,
each household i's
consumption set
is a subset of this
L-dimensional space.
Namely, they're, like,
subsistence or minimal bundles.
So the amount of good l cannot
be lower than some x lower bar
l per household i.
This is the heterogeneity.
It can depend on household i.
And let's have utility of
household i over vector
x just be the
difference to a power
between xl and those
minimal subsistence bundles.
So the heterogeneity is in
the subsistence bundles,
which can vary over households.
But the sigmas are the same.
It's not sigma i.
It's sigma, common, across
all of the households.
So if we had an
economy represented
by these consumption sets
and these preferences,
we could look at their
indirect utility.
And if you do the math,
you get this ugly thing.
But it does have the
right form, ai p plus bp
times wi for household i.
And then you add it up--
namely, add up this
guy over households i.
And you get the expression
at the bottom of the slide.
And in particular,
the heterogeneity
in the subsistence
bundles is right here.
So they're all different.
They have different minimums.
But miraculously, we're able
to add up those minimums
and call it kind of a
pseudo-subsistence bundle
for an aggregated
representative household who
would have the indirect
utility that's written out here
at the bottom of the slide.
I don't have too many more
examples in front of me today,
but I mean, I do want to give--
I did want to give
you one example,
because this indirect utility
space is a bit different
and a bit abstract.
So here, we actually start with
underlying utility functions.
I said all that in words.
So now, let's go to the
normative representative
household.
I should say, it's the same guy.
It's the same person.
It just has two characteristics.
It can be used for positive
economics in the sense
that it's predictive of what
the entire economy is doing,
and it can also be used
to make welfare statements
by a rank ordering over
the utility function.
But there's not, like, one
representative normative
household and one representative
positive household.
It's a given
representative household
with both positive and
normative characteristics,
and we are about to go
through the normative part.
So let's have the individual
demand functions--
this is-- the first
little paragraph
here is the positive part, that
these demands can be derived
as if through an aggregated
demand function given
the total wealth of the economy.
Now, we want to ask
the normative question.
Given a set of individual
demand functions,
can we find this fictitious
household i star such
that Pareto optimal
allocations in the economy
can be thought of as coming from
this representative household
maximizing utility?
I keep emphasizing
fictitious, amazing,
because I don't
want you to think
that this is a real person.
It's a construct.
So let's take our
underlying economy, which
we've been reading this line for
the last two or three lectures.
Underlying economy is script
E characterized by consumption
sets, utility functions
over all of the households,
production possibility
sets over all of the firms,
some aggregate endowment w bar.
Now, finally, we define a
normative representative
household with two
characteristics.
If we started with
an allocation x and y
and we found an alternative
allocation x prime,
y prime, which Pareto
dominates x, y, meaning
at least as good for some and
strictly better for others.
Then under u star,
evaluated that
to some of the prime bundle is
greater than u star evaluated
at the original bundle.
In other words, it's
kind of intuitive,
but it's not always true.
Here, for the definition
of Pareto dominance,
we're looking at individual
allocations over all
the households and
trying to find something
that's at least as good
for some and strictly
better for the others.
If we can find this amazing u
star, then all we need to do
is evaluate the
aggregates, namely,
the aggregate under x prime
and aggregate under x.
And what we need--
and apart from condition
2, the only thing we need--
is that u star assigns
a higher value.
In other words, it's easier to
look for Pareto improvements
just by looking
at the value under
the pseudo-utility function
evaluated at the aggregates.
So the second thing is
similar, but not quite.
Instead of starting with the
underlying micro distributions,
suppose that we had a feasible
allocation x and y, as before,
and an alternative feasible
allocation, x prime, y prime.
And we're given
that under u star,
the utility is higher
at the aggregates.
Then we want to
claim that there is
an alternative feasible
allocation which
Pareto dominates.
In other words, is
this xi allocation
Pareto optimal or not?
Not, if we can find
another allocation,
x prime, which
dominates, but dominates
in the sense of u star.
And u star is just
evaluating these things
at the summed up aggregates.
And actually, there's a subtlety
here which is important.
You can't just stop.
You may have to redistribute.
Well, here's what
I mean by that.
If this is true, there exists
an alternative feasible
allocation, tilde--
x tilde, y tilde--
such that the summation over x
tilde of the demands and so on
allocations is exactly the same
aggregate as under the prime,
and the y's aren't changing.
So this kind of
subtle step here,
it doesn't mean,
necessarily, that you
can stop with x prime
and y prime and claim
victory, because
if you stop there,
it's not necessarily true
that everyone's better off--
or no worse off.
Some people may be damaged.
In fact, maybe this is the
time to talk about free trade.
When we were looking
at that lecture,
we represented a country
by some indifference curve
as if from some u
star representative
household for the
whole country to look
at the direction of trade.
So we were getting
the country to agree
we get demand in
a positive sense
by looking at that
representative agent
indifference curve.
And it might have appeared
that the whole country could be
made better off by free trade.
On the other hand,
you saw in detail,
in two different lectures--
three, really--
that not everyone
is made off under free trade.
Remember, the households
that are relatively well
endowed with a factor that's
abundant are helped by exports.
The other guys are hurt.
Et cetera.
So how can we claim that
free trade makes everyone
better off?
We have to redistribute,
which is not always done.
Hence, people complain
about free trade
and they want tariffs.
Anyway, I'm belaboring
the fact that this lecture
is consistent with
the other ones,
except now, we're
finally in a position
to be able to talk explicitly
about redistribution
as a necessary part of
making everyone better off.
In other words, to
sum up, even when
we have preferences aggregating,
it is not necessarily the case
that everyone is made better
off under some alternative
allocation xi prime.
You have to redistribute
the underlying bundles.
So let's do the same
definition, but do it
in the space of indirect utility
instead of direct utility.
Suppose we're given
a vector of wealth,
as in the distribution
of income,
and some aggregate wealth
that corresponds with that.
p is a price vector.
Define the indirect
utility functions, again,
as we have been doing.
Now, we want to find
this miraculous star
person, this normative
representative household,
i star, that has an
indirect utility function v
star, evaluated at
the price vector
p and the aggregate
wealth w bar.
And there are two
conditions, 1 and 2,
that correspond with the one
in the allocation space xi
on the previous slide.
Namely, if you have
two configurations,
you start with a p and w wealth.
You're looking at an
alternative, p prime, w prime,
price vector in
wealth, such that
looking at the actual
real indirect utilities
of all the households, some
people are no worse off
and other people are
strictly better off
under the prime allocation.
So that's the statement
of Pareto dominance
in the space of indirect
utility functions.
And what we want
is a way to do it
more easily through the
star, the indirect utility
of the normative
representative household,
which is just evaluating
the alternative scenario,
p prime and w prime.
But it's w prime added up
over all of the households.
So we're just using
aggregate wealth here
on the left-hand side,
and also aggregate wealth
on the right-hand side, when
we're thinking about trying to,
quote, unquote,
"Pareto dominate."
So just like before, it's
very intuitive, but amazing
when it's true, that the way
to look for Pareto dominating
allocations is just to evaluate
the aggregated allocations
and see whether you get a
higher value under v star.
Likewise, going the other way,
start with the aggregate wealth
and price vector p.
Look at an alternative scenario,
p prime and w bar prime, such
that the utility
under v star is higher
in the alternative allocation.
If that's true, then there
exists an alternative income
distribution w
prime which adds up
to the aggregate wealth
in the alternative--
the dominating allocation
with the prime on it.
Now, again, let's pause here.
This alternative income
means an income distribution
that works under
the prime scenario
relative to the initial income
distribution in the baseline
without the prime.
So we have to have the
freedom to distribute wealth,
not necessarily according
to private ownership, when
we change the prices and so on,
but potentially, with transfers
of wealth across the agents--
giving to some, taking
away from others,
as in the second
welfare theorem,
where we've seen this kind
of redistribution before.
So we find this
alternative such that we're
getting Pareto dominance in
the underlying indirect utility
functions.
Not worse for anyone and
strictly better for some.
So how do we find this
representative household,
or the representative household
with this normative property?
Same guy, Gorman Polar form,
although this is getting
stated as a proposition.
If we have this Gorman Polar
form with this particular way
that heterogeneity is entering
into the indirect utility
functions, then when we look at
the indirect utility function
under the aggregate, being in
particular the sum of the ai
plus b times w, that is
the normative household.
We already proved the
positive part earlier.
Now, it's normative.
I put positive and
normative both on the slide
to make the point
that, as I've said,
we're not looking for a
normative household that's
different from the
positive household.
We're looking for this
representative household
with both attributes.
We proved the positive
thing earlier.
Now, we need to prove
the normative part.
So suppose we have those Gorman
Polar form, in particular,
to figure out which direction
we're going from the condition
1, this guy here.
Condition 1.
So we have a rank ordering under
the actual indirect utility
functions being explicit
about household i.
So under the vi's,
not worse for some
and strictly better for others.
So we're given that.
Now, we want to prove that
when we evaluate under v star
using the aggregates,
we get strict dominance.
So let's look at it. v star
under the aggregate alternative
prime allocation is-- and this
is just now writing things out.
This is the definition of the
indirect utility function star,
the one that's going to work.
And then as we keep going
across these equations,
we recognize, again, the
taking the summation over I
out in front of all of it,
that we're just adding up
the indirect utility functions.
But again, we're given
not worse for some
and strictly better for others.
So when we add up the
indirect utility functions
under the prime
allocation and compare it
to the original allocation,
it must be strict dominance.
And then if you reverse
the ordering of these
vi's, collecting terms and
going back toward the left-hand
side--
not under prime, but
under the baseline--
you would get this
star indirect utility
for the representative
household.
So the bottom line is the v star
under prime strictly greater
than v star under the baseline.
And we proved one.
The second thing we
want to prove is this--
that we have an
initial allocation
and we're looking at a prime
allocation that gives higher
indirect utility for the
aggregated household.
And then we want to
find a way to assign
wealth that makes everyone
better off, essentially.
So again, from 2, we
have this as a given,
that v star returns a higher
value under the prime relative
to the baseline.
We want to construct
an alternative income
distribution-- seems like
that might be hard to do--
that makes everyone,
in fact, I'm
going to show you,
strictly better off.
Actually, strict
dominance for everyone.
And it's actually very
constructive and intuitive.
We're already given here
that we have this equation
30 at the aggregates,
the left-hand side
being greater than
the right-hand side.
So take the difference
and call it c.
It's a positive constant
now, the rest of the thing
is just writing out what v
star is under prime and v star
is under the baseline,
and then collecting terms.
The only reason to do this part
using the definition of v star
is to go searching
for the wealth levels
that we want, namely, let's give
each household their proportion
of c.
There are i households
in the economy.
Give each one c over i.
So we start with the baseline
in terms of the indirect utility
function.
We add on to the baseline
this positive constant.
And we want that to be
the indirect utility
per household i under
the alternative.
So now, we can just solve
this equation for wi.
It's almost mechanical.
These are, though, the required
new distributions of wealth
that will work.
Why does it work?
Well, working backwards,
if you give them this,
then we have this equation.
And you can also see,
because we've just
added a constant to the
indirect utility function,
that each household i
under the alternative
is having more utility
than under the baseline.
That's this vi of p prime
w prime, vi of p and wi,
plus this proportional constant.
So it's almost trivial, because
now, we've gone the other way.
We proved 2, this thing.
So we've succeeded, if they
have these Gorman Polar forms,
in constructing a
pseudo-utility function
over the indirect utility
function over the aggregates.
Questions?
OK.
So now let's go back
to the Pareto problem.
In particular, we did
a version of this slide
when we did the second
welfare theorem.
We have this underlying economy
with consumption, preferences,
production functions,
aggregate, endowments,
satisfying non-negative orthant,
and differentiable convex
production sets or
concave transformations,
non-negative
aggregate resources,
consumption sets
having interior points,
utility functions
being strictly concave,
and also an interior point with
respect to aggregate resources.
I'm rushing a bit, but
only because you've
seen this slide before.
If all of that is
true, then we can
solve this Pareto problem to
get Pareto optimal allocations.
This is just maximizing lambda
weighted sums of utilities
subject to consumption
being feasible,
production being feasible,
and the resource constraints
being satisfied.
Demand equals supply.
I should say,
allocations are feasible
given endowments in
the production set.
Problem?
What are the lambdas?
We move the lambdas around, we
get different Pareto optimum.
That's what we did with
the second welfare theorem.
And we've used this with risk
sharing in many applications
previously.
But we had to keep
track of the lambdas.
Here's what happens with
the representative consumer.
No more lambdas.
Now, we just maximize utility.
Well, this x is now
aggregate consumption.
Production sets are
the same as before.
Resource constraint's the
same in the aggregate.
I mean, x is aggregate.
Aggregated x is entering into
the pseudo utility function u
star, and we want to
find the highest u.
Remember why-- because we
already proved this, right?
It's enough to look at
you star in the aggregates
in the sense of satisfying
both these conditions.
And that's what
we're doing here.
We're just looking in
the space of aggregates
under this pseudo-utility
function u star.
If we're not maximizing
it, then when
we move in a direction
that improves it,
we're actually improving
the welfare of all
of the individual households.
We'll, in a sense,
Pareto dominate.
So simple to write,
but extremely powerful.
And this-- so this is
contemporary macro.
This is what is usually
assumed in macroeconomics
or aggregative economics.
No reference to redistributions
or wealth, underlying wealths,
or whatever.
So mesmerized by the
individual household
that we forget to spell
out the underpinnings,
and in particular, the
assumptions that are needed.
Are they satisfied?
No, typically not.
That previous lecture
on micro data,
we saw that income expansion
paths are a special case.
In particular, there are
non-linear expansion paths.
As we change income, expenditure
shares go up for some goods.
We call them luxury goods.
Expenditure shares go
down for other goods.
We call them necessities.
And so on.
So that's what's in the data.
Engel found this very early on.
And we presented
other applications,
Giffen goods being an extreme
version of the case when
the income effects,
through necessities, are
so strong that they
dominate the price effects.
Well, maybe one can hope
that as an approximation,
even though we
would not literally
satisfy the assumptions,
that those income effects
come close to canceling out.
That's kind of the best case.
Macro with micro underpinnings.
It's a reference to
the trade lecture.
I've already given
you my spiel on that
this afternoon about
the gains to trade
and the fact that we have
losers, although the theorem is
telling us that if we have
representative consumer, then
we're safe in looking
at the max, both
the positive and the normative.
But it will require
redistribution
of a particular kind.
And finally, the economic
impact of COVID-19.
I put that in there to
remind you of things
that we found in that
lecture when I was reviewing
what the impact has been.
And we had relatively
poor households
who were unemployed cutting
back on expenditure,
or potentially
increasing expenditure
only if they got the
government money,
and also looked at
higher-income households
through JP Morgan's data set.
And those guys had different
expenditure patterns.
So it does not seem as though
these effects are canceling out
when we actually look at
the underlying micro data.
I mean, to cancel
out we wouldn't
see anything happening--
well, I should be careful here.
There is an aggregate
adverse shock, obviously.
We're all suffering from
it, at least indirectly.
So the aggregates are down.
But then the question
is, do other changes
balance out at the aggregate?
And the data I presented to
you suggest that's not true.
So questions?
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a
question about the slide 22?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: 22?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, here.
I'm a little bit confusing that.
Do we do assume that
the sum of x prime
will equal to the sum of x here?
Because in the slide
21, we say that,
at the [? center ?]
of the allocation
should be the same as original.
And the sum of production--
the production is the
equal to the original.
So when you go from 21 to
22, do we still assume this?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: It's
only implicit in the sense
that we're looking at individual
wealths and aggregating it up.
So I agree, it's
probably not obvious,
but there are just
two representations,
one in this space
of indirect utility
functions with the
parameters p and w,
and the other and the actual
underlying allocations.
Another way to put that is
that if we-- where is it?
If we went with--
can't find it.
Yeah.
Take, as an example,
this utility function
and the associated indirect
utilities, these guys.
You could go back and forth.
You could do it one way
or do it the other way.
You're going to get
the same answer.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I get it.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
OK.
So that's Gorman
aggregation, with a lot
of the pieces coming together.
Next time, we're going to go
back in the other direction.
We're going to ask, if we
don't do anything special
like this parametrically,
does economic theory
put any restrictions
on data at all?
And the answer is
going to be yes,
so we'll talk about
theory that can
be rejected in the data,
which is a good thing.
Otherwise, there's no content.
So that's all for today.
Thank you for coming.